in a recent video I made about nature
and its place in the religious and
spiritual life of many contemporary
people especially in the Nordic
countries in Scandinavia I included an
interview with Professor David tfel one
of the leading historians of religions
in all of Sweden and perhaps even the
world and actually my old Professor this
was a really interesting discussion and
David is an amazing speaker so I thought
it would be worthwhile to actually post
the entire full interview for you to
watch we go into even more detail about
all these topics and all the nuances of
the research and all the stuff that's
going on in this field right now which
is so interesting so without further Ado
here is my full interview with Professor
David
tfel maybe you can begin by introducing
yourself and what you
do okay so my name is David turel I'm a
Swedish historian of religion I'm a
professor in the study of religions at
sedon University
um I have had a couple of different
interests in my research I began in
Islamic Studies doing field workor in
Iran and I wrote couple of books and
articles on
um sort of the the emotional personal
side of uh Shiite piety in in an Iranian
context and then I my second field was
uh Pentecostal Christianity so I did
similar studies uh graphy and fieldwork
based studies of Pentecostalism and I
focus on Pentecostalism in uh Romany in
the Romany communities so among Roma
people there is this Pentecostal
revivalism going on and I have studied
that and then I swwa to my third sort of
field of Interest which is uh
secularization and um sort of the
marginalization of religion in uh
Scandinavian mainstream
culture and uh I have focused on sort of
the subtleties of what it means to be
secular so not so much the big
sociological sort of historical
overviews as the personal aspects of
secularity so for instance one of the
things or my latest book deals with u
nature Romanticism and sort of nature as
a place
for um existential reflections and sort
of heartfelt feelings among people who
think of themselves as
secular and you just mentioned your
latest book gr sk's folk and in general
the the research you've been doing for
the last few years which like you said
is about nature Romanticism and people's
relationships and experiences in nature
and I think primarily focused on the
Nordic country side or is yes it's it's
the Nordic country so we this is a
project we've conducted research in in
all the Scandinavian countries and
Finland and Estonia
so can you give a like an overview of
this phenomenon and what you are
studying and the field Yeah so basically
if if you ask people if you interview
people in this part of the world and I
mean Sweden then is allegedly one of the
most secular countries in the world in
some um surveys as many as 85% of the
population will say that religion has no
place in their life whatsoever so this
is a very strong sort of non-religious
stance among many people uh but if you
look a little deeper into that
phenomenon you'll find that there are
lots of instances of what we can
recognize as religion anyway for
instance they are paying members in
churches and they baptize their kids and
they have biblical names and they
believe and they pray and they believe
in all kinds of stuff so they're not as
secular as they think and one of those
instances one instance where this sort
of secularity crumbles a little bit is
when it comes to their relation to the
landscape and the forest and nature in
general so basically if you interview
people in Stockholm for instance um
about their view of religion many will
respond that one of the things I mean
they will say that they're not religious
they have know they don't like religion
they're critical to religion it's too
much power and it's unscientific and all
kinds of ideas uh but then they will say
many of them that uh but on the other
hand sometimes when I take a walk in the
park or when I go to the archipelago or
when I hike in the
mountains you know I can feel something
you know let's say something like this
so people spontaneously make a
connection in this part of the world
make a connection between their own
experience in nature and what they
believe religious people experience in
the church or in the mosque or in the
synagogue so uh in one way to express as
that is to say that many people in this
country would sort of subscribe to the
notion that the forest is my church and
this this idea that the forest is my
church uh the N nature is my Cathedral
and I mean phrases like this are also
extremely common if you look in in
poetry and in in pop songs and in in in
in fiction and in people's uh
autobiographies and so on so this is a
very this a tro it's a Trope it's like a
motif in Scandinavian
culture um so we wanted to explore that
Trope and what we did was basically to
interview people who are walking in the
Forest hiking in the mountains visiting
national parks and the nature reserves
areas and interview them about their
ideas about nature what it means to them
and and so
on um yeah so that's the sort of General
uh aim of of of the research that's
really fascinating so you mentioned in
your book uh various types of
experiences that people have in these
circumstances when they're out in nature
what are some examples of of these kinds
of experiences yeah soing yes so I mean
it depends a little bit on the type of
nature that we are dealing with so in
Denmark for instance where uh where they
have their sort of pristine
beaches I mean opening up to the wild
sea and to the Atlantic Ocean and people
will go there and they will be felt to
be blown through by the Atlantic winds
and so on then they have slightly
different Sensations they might be more
dramatic experiences in a Swedish and
also Finnish and Estonian
setting the the feeling is primarily
sort of a a sense of of calmness and
homeliness so the people I've
interviewed around in central Sweden
they will think of the forest they they
walk in the forest and they will feel a
sense of being taken care of they will
have a sense that the trees and the
landscape is like a nurturing kind place
which sort of Embraces them with with
its benevolence somehow uh so that is a
strong thing the feeling of being taken
care of another feeling is the sense of
of that this is something completely
different this is a very prominent sort
of feature in the interviews they live
their hectic City lives and then they go
out to the forest and the forest is a
place for taking a break for peace for
something else it's it's very much a
contrast between City Life and Forest uh
sort of life so it's it's a
contrast it's also a place where they
get in touch with sort of sides of their
inner emotional life that they
rarely um get in touch with otherwise so
for instance if they have sort of
unresolved issues or there maybe there's
some sadness or there's some trauma or
there are some
unsolved relational problems these will
sort of surface in the forest so they
can think about them and they can think
through them and uh people can cry in
the many people say that they they will
sit and cry in the forest or they will
sort of get in touch with their
innermost
feelings um which is another feature
another thing is a sense of authenticity
right that this is something that is
real and that is you know they they they
become real uh when going into the
forest they they they connect to real
leaves and soil and trees and and in
this there's also in all of this there
is this underlying criticism of urban
Modern Life uh that it's sort of um
artificial and and
unhealthy there's a lovely section in
your book where you describe these
people's experiences almost like nature
being a mirror for their own lives and
their own yes yeah that this is um
another sort of feature that comes back
again and
again and um I think I call this a it's
like the Nature has a metaphorical
meaning so so I realized quite quickly
when I started doing these interviews
that there are two Landscapes at play in
these nature interactions and one is the
outer landscape with the trees and and
the the mountains and the little rivers
and the forests and everything uh but
then there's what you can then call an
inner landscape which is like the inner
landscape of the uh interlocutors the
people have interviewed uh their own
lives I mean their own Liv stories their
relations their journey through life if
you want and it's as if they constantly
mirror their inner life in the outer
landscape so for instance if I ask in
the interviews uh tell me about this
Forest uh many will respond like yeah I
had a a stressful couple of years you
know so they will they will answer about
themselves when you ask about the forest
and so there are many instances then
when this what happens in your inner
life is sort of you you get hold of it
or you can see it or it's illustrated by
what happens in the outer landscape so
take the the classical instance of
walking following a path I mean it's
very easy for us as as a species I think
to think of our own life as a journey
through a landscape I think it comes
very naturally to us uh we can think of
our Our Lives as a journey we are
walking our life is a path and we're
walking this path and we come across
different type of Landscapes and
different types of
of situations just like a road that goes
through a
landscape um so this is something common
I think for humans all all over the
world and in this among these secular
Scandinavians then it would be something
like uh okay so for instance if you walk
through a dark forest and suddenly you
come up to a hill and the landscape
opens up so you get this view over over
over the landscape and you can see far
away and you don't really see where the
path is leading so this sense of of the
UN sort of the open-endedness of the
landscape then reminds you well this is
like my life my life is also open ated I
don't know where I will go I don't know
if I'll stay in this relation in this
job in this city or if I will move or
you know so it's there this connection
being made I have another beautiful
example from one of the
interviews one of the guys I interviewed
had diabetes so he was um suffering from
this
disease and he told told me the story
where he had uh been walking in in the
forest and he stumbled across this
blossoming apple tree so it's an apple
tree and it's blossoming in the spring
so it's full of white flowers and it's
very beautiful and he sort of stunned by
the beauty of this tree and then he
walks up to it and he you know sort of
looks very closely on on the individual
flowers and he discovers that he can't
find even one flower that is perfect and
flawless I mean every flower is a little
bit tilted it's some of the leaves have
fallen off as I mean none of them are
perfect and then he realizes from this
sort of experience in the outer
landscape that uh being a bit
flawed is the this is the natural state
of things nature is not filled of
perfect samples every all of them are a
bit flawed so being having a a a
chronical disease like this this is not
a deviation from the normal State it's
not an anomaly it's this is the normal
state of things and this is also what we
experience as beautiful so suddenly by
seeing this apple tree he he gets a
different perspective on his own uh
personal situation beauty is imperfect
beauty is imperfect and it's nor it's
natural this is what it is like uh and
this metaphoric metaphor there are many
instances like this but what happens
then when you connect metaphorically to
the landscape in this sense is that
um uh there is a very strong sense of
connection and this is the most
prominent sort of feature or or thing
that uh the informants say that they
feel a sense of connection they get a
sense of connection with the landscape
when they are out in the forest um and
that's understandable if you think of
this metaphorical connection because
what you realize then is that what
happens in my life in my very personal
life journey in my inner landscape it
also goes on out there among the trees
and the animals and the birds and and
the leaves this this this combination of
growth and uh and Decay for instance so
we have these leaves they are decaying
this tree is dying something in it it's
dying but because it's dying it will
hibernate and it will sort of gather
energy and when spring comes it will
reblossom this connection between
between the inner world and the
processes that happens in my inner life
in my inner sort of uh
landscape uh when you feel that that is
reflected in the outer landscape you get
the sense of connection so I which in
its turn then creates the sense of not
being so lonely because I am this I mean
people will tell me that in in the city
when they live their hectic City lives
with their social media and they're
going on the subway and you know the the
city the urban modern uh life uh they
feel a bit like a satellite like sort of
they are alone they are an entity of
their own moving through this hectic
hectic City but when they go out into
the forest they feel that their inner
processes are going on outside of them
as well so they are part of a bigger
process dying and decaying and living
and sadness and happiness and coming and
going and all these things are happening
outside of them and inside of them so
they feel less lonely and uh they also
feel less uh feel that death is less
threatening because death okay death
will maybe strike this particular entity
but the processes that happens inside of
it and outside of it they will go on so
death is not as big a thing and they
really believe in death they are secular
they don't believe in a Transcendent
reality outside of this world or
continuation uh after death for for this
individual but there's some kind of
continuation because the processes are
going on so um and this I I suppose if
you come to the Scandinavian countries
and you don't know about this how people
are like here they might be a bit
introvert and they go to the forest
alone and you might feel they are very
lonely and I mean there there are many
stories of people coming from other
places coming here and thinking this is
very strange they must be very lonely
since they go out alone but if you
interview these people uh they go out
they go from the City full of people
they go out take the subway out to some
place and they walk out into the forest
they sit alone under a tree and reflect
for a couple of hours and then they go
back and when you interview them about
what happened they say well now I feel a
bit less lonely so it's it's a very
paradoxical thing but it's kind of
understandable also I think it's really
interesting I was struck when I was
reading the book uh with some of the the
more profound or dramatic experiences
like for example you mentioned some
people experience almost like a death of
the the self and the ego and yeah what
what you call the numinous which is R of
Autos yes term right
um which as readers of the book might
think well that sounds like a religious
experience whatever that means but do
these people themselves see these
experiences as religious or how do they
you know in in this uh Scandinavian
secular mainstream
culture uh people are very um sensitive
about the very word of religion and
religious and spiritual they are these
words are imbued with so many
associations and political history and
a sort of discursive history which makes
them very difficult to use for them so
many will say well this is almost a
religious experience but when they say
the word religious they will do like
this like quotation marks or it's almost
sacred because they're not comfortable
with the words so they themselves are
not calling them religious but
actually if you because I've also
interviewed people who are sort of
believing and professed Christians and
they have the same kind of experiences
and those who have the strongest nature
spiritual
experiences in in this country are
people who are also believing Christians
and I suppose also from other religions
but most of them are Christians uh and
this means that one way to define a
religious experience in my material is
to say it's a nature experience that
happens to a Christian person you know
or someone who has a Christian language
because if you look at the the content
of the actual
experiences so one of those seculars
they might say they they're running in
the forest and they have this sense of
interconnectedness or connection with
the landscape and what happens Within Me
happens without and I am an entity but
I'm also connected to a greater world
and to Nature and to the other species
and to the ecological systems and to the
universe and we are all a part of this
um and when they especially if you if
you walk for a couple of hours in the
landscape or if you run or if you're
really exhausted because you've been
doing physical exercise there um this
sense of sort of yourself sort of
dissolving will be more prominent
because you are so tired that you can't
really think or use your brain so you
become a a body you have this sensation
of becoming a physical body in a
physical world and this sense of being
alive among other things which are also
alive and we are just alive here
together uh which is in one way similar
to a sense of ego dissolvement that we
find in traditional
religion uh so in this sense and if if
if there was a Christian person who was
a beli sort of believing Christian with
a Christian language and uh a Muslim for
that matter or or a Jew or Hindu or
whatever then they will use that
language to express that exact thing so
they'll say well I had the sense of when
they see beauty they will say this is
like the grace I feel an experience of
the grace of God or the beauty of
creation and but I'm not sure that the
experience is so different it's just the
language is is different and of course
language forms experience so it's it's
complicated but there is also of course
a difference I mean it's not just the
same and the difference lies in the
sort of the world viw or the
interpretation of these experiences in
terms of so the met the metaphysical
consequences they get because they
really don't have the secularist that
I've interviewed they really don't
have um a belief in a Transcendent
reality in the sense of a continuation
after this life of this individual self
or something like that and I actually
made in in the end of the book I make
this comparison
with um a section from St Augustine when
he he has this famous question so this
is fourth century Christian uh thinker
and he has this question where he asked
what is it that I love when I say that I
love my God I say that I love God says
St Augustine so what do I mean by that
what is it I love when I say that I love
God it's quite a good philosophical
question what is it what is the object
of the religious feeling and then he
comes to some kind of conclusion about
that where he
lists a couple of things which which he
is not loving when he loves God and that
is like all the temporal things food
that will disappear and uh a drink that
will disappear I love something that is
eternal and if you take that uh that
phrase from
him or that sort of his response to his
own question and you remove all the
negative words so instead of saying I
I'm not
Desiring uh water that disappears or
food that the decays or love that will
be ended by death and you just remove
all the not then you will get something
that quite close to what my respondents
it's almost like the opposite yeah it's
almost opposite because it's and this
connects also to this um sort of
ecological movement and and the
engagement for for climate change and
for a dying planet and speci is being
extinct and and so on so it's actually
the fact that this tree or this Forest
it can disappear and if it disappears it
will never come back and I love this I
mean the
respondents they feel this strong
connection to a world that actually can
disappear so they are not some kind of
neoplatonists who believe that this
world is a mirror image of something
that is eternal this is actually what's
there it's the physical natural world
it's there and it's fantastic and I'm a
part of it and I can dissolve into it
and myself is sort of interconnected to
it and uh they love it in with a
religious passion and it can disappear
so death is there so we need to which
also then creates a moral imperative to
actually take care of it because it can
actually
disappear it's really beautiful like you
said you've been focusing on on the the
Nordic countries and Sweden in
particular would you say that this is a
global phenomenon or is it very
localized in in this part of the world
uh well it's it's a bit of both so um in
one sense there is a northern
European uh sort of uh interest or uh
there's there's an old cultural heritage
in this part of the world of nature of
turning to nature which goes deep and
which find which can be found in
pre-christian times and and it's been
there a long long time in this part of
the world I mean we can also find that
type of attitudes in many parts of the
world but there's something specific I
think in a European context at least
between the Germanic and the the Latin
uh parts of Europe where the the
northern Germanic cultures have been
more nature oriented in some sense for
for Millennia so there is this deep
historical roots and I don't want to
deny those but there's also uh and then
there's something called culture
specific or regionally specific related
to uh sort of the national romantic
Stories the type of uh narratives about
uh about swedes and Danes and Norwegians
that were um sort of U cultivated by
natural Romanticism at the turn of the
last century so there's a story about
nature love being a part of swedishness
which has also formed and a part of a
national self-identity and which built
of course on things that were there
before and but sort of exaggerated them
and the same we find in Norway and and
Finland and Estonia and and and all
these countries uh so there's this
connected to a specialness in in the on
a discursive level in the
narratives uh but then it's also a
global thing because it's U humans have
always connected to the landscape and
this is a part of what we are as a
species and also it's global in the
sense that there's a sort of an urban
middle
class uh culture that is global so if
you go to Urban I mean this this type of
nature romantic style or attitudes in
Sweden are mostly found in the big
cities I mean if you want to buy the
gears to go out to to climb mountains
you'll have to go to the very City
Center of Stockholm because it's an
urban phenomenon because it's for urban
people that nature is this other place
that you go to explore and find peace
and and something else and that type of
sort of uh you could call it sort of
city Urban upper midle class if you want
you could call it bouras but that would
be to stretch it a bit too far I suppose
but middle class Urban globalized
secular culture that is found in many
places so I have been to Iran a lot and
in in tan there are Urban middle class
seculars who would go hiking in the
mountains who would have the same kind
of experience I heard the same movement
is there in laor and Karachi and in
Pakistan it happens in Japan it happens
in North America South America it's all
over the place so it's a part sort of a
global uh Global culture in that sense
also you talked about the ex a cultural
and historical aspect behind this is is
that but in the book you also me you
also mentioned that there might be
biological reasons behind it what what's
what's your stance on that is it is it
primary or yes uh well there are there
is actually quite a lot of research on
the from a
biochemical pharmaceutical sort of
Natural Science perspective on the the
health benefits of walking in forests
and they have all kinds of theories and
I I cannot assess them because I'm not a
natural scientist but they have um you
know there are this certain biochemical
uh substances that you can find in
certain plants that are beneficial for
our immune system uh and there are uh
Earth bacteria that are good for for us
and and obviously just walking and being
outdoors and breathing fresh air and and
moving your body is I mean Health uh
inducing in all kinds of ways so there
are those aspects but I strongly believe
that there are also I mean those there
might be truth to those explanations
but there's also this um cultural
expectancy on nature to be Health uh
inducing um uh so and if you if there's
a cultural expectancy and I have also
some a chapter on a psychological theory
that can explain this which we find in
Psychology in psychology of religion but
also actually in mainstream psychology
as sort of a I think it's quite a a
dominant Theory nowadays uh which is a
theory called uh predictive coding so
the idea is basically that and it
relates to emotional responses to to to
environment so the idea is basically
that our brain through
Evolution has uh evolved to be able to
anticipate what's going to happen next
so we are walking in the forest and a
bear comes comes out uh and what happens
well we our brain then uh this is the
lingo of This neuroscientific research
so the brain will respond by preparing
the body for what it expects will now
come so we when we see a bear we will
expect to have to fight or flee so it
will start those processes in our body
which are we need for fighting and
fleeing which is pumping adrenaline
raising the pulse or whatever doing all
kinds of stuff and when we when we our
conscious mind experience expences this
uh uh change of our body this bodily
change we will construe it as fear so
what is fear well fear is the uh the
conscious experience of a physical
change now let's say we get to KN know
this bear and it's a nice bear and it's
a friendly uh domesticated bear and we
become best friends with the bear and we
hug it every day and we love this bear
and then a a year later we will walk in
the same forest and this bear comes out
now we know that this is not fleeing or
fighting it means cuddling and taking a
nap so then our body will respond
preparing our body for cuddling and
napping creating senses of calmness and
slowing down and you know all those
feelings so this is what emotion is sort
of the the motor program of a body the
body responding for what the brain
thinks will come next so this means that
the emotional reaction to something Al
land cape for instance or a person or a
situation uh is dependent on the
expectation of what it will lead to so
we can take another example let's say
you come to you have had a hard time in
school when you were a kid it was hard
it was tough you were bullied and then
you come to the school again 20 years
later you'll come to the same this
actually happened to me yesterday
because I visited my old high school and
uh you came to the same place where I
was as a 14year old and you walk in the
same corridors and suddenly I feel this
anxiety Rising because it was tough to
be a 14-year-old and it was for most of
us and you know this adolescent time was
very hard uh so when you come to the
place associated with that
place my body thinks oh this now I have
to deal with all these problems so it
creates preparation which I then
construe us anxiety and
fear uh or let's say I would visit my
grandmother's house where I had a
beautiful childhood and I was there with
my grandmother and she gave me you know
hot chocolate and you know it was so
safe and and lovely if I would go there
now maybe I would become sleepy and a
bit you know sad perhaps in in in a in a
calm way because this is the expect what
I expect from this place yeah so if you
have this sort of theory in mind you can
ask why do people from this part of the
world get a sense of comfort and
familiarity and
uh touching getting in touch with their
emotions when they go to the forest well
it's because their their system expects
this Forest to trigger those emotions
and then you can ask why does the mo
Forest trigger those emotion well it's
because they have grown up in a culture
and this is very true if you grown up in
Sweden where the school all the children
books every poet uh musical text the
general culture the law the the
curriculum for for education all of it
tells this story again and again and
again the forest is a benevolent
beautiful place where you're supposed to
feel uh safe and spiritual and calm and
which calls then on the in in its turn
for a historical explanation so this is
just a long detour to motivate why we
need history of religions to understand
something like this and because this
cultural sort of situation then has been
created by a history yeah
uh which I then sort of go through that
makes me think of we have a summer house
in Western Sweden which we go to every
summer and I associate that with my
childhood and you know all those happy
memories and I can very much experience
the same thing when we go there each
summer that you sort of enter another
you become calm somehow yeah just
because you associate that place another
thing I I thought about was that which
might connect to that but that um when I
was a kid I had a habit for a period of
always falling asleep or watching The
Simpsons on the TV when I fell asleep
and eventually it got to the point where
I could put on The Simpsons midday I
would always fall asleep because my
brain is soate it that way with sleeping
yeah that's how it works and this
childhood thing is very important
because most of the people we have
interviewed they have gotten to know the
forest in their childhood so if you ask
what do you see it tell me about this
place many will say well I suppose it's
childhood memories and it's childhood is
very important very important and this
is also one of the things that creates
this sense of
authenticity because if if you think
back I mean until we were maybe 11 12 or
something in one way I I can feel like
this at least I was myself the most yeah
up until that age and then when when you
became older and grown up you started to
have all this wearing this masks or
pretending to be someone and U you you
sort of uh changed yourself in an
artificial way so if you want to come
back to your authentic true me well that
would be the 11-year-old me somehow and
you get and when you go to the place
where you played as a
kid like just like with the Simpson case
well then you get in touch with that
authentic self that you used to be and
this also explains in one way why people
become a bit childish in the forest
because they are so they can also get
into touch with uh not just their sort
of uh childhood self but also to the
kind of moods and feelings and and
playful attitudes that they had as a kid
so for instance they can talk to trees
many people talk to trees they will you
know hug the trees or you know have this
feeling that they are personal entities
and um that is sort of a childhood play
that sort of they get in touch with uh
even as adults
yeah this is such a fascinating topic
and and I think a very important one
because it is such a major part of many
people's
uh well lives in the modern world so I
think having a way to study it in the
way that you do is is really valuable in
many ways um thank you so much for for
talking to us than is there anything you
have coming up that you would like to
promote
or uh well I have I have a new book
coming up about um religiousity and sort
of um the human capacity to construe the
world in a religious way it's
unfortunately in Swedish it's called um
uh the subtitle is on human abilities to
to uh animate the world yeah I suppose
would be a translation since this
interview was actually recorded in
October 2022 the book that David
mentions here has actually since then
been released and goes under the Swedish
title which again if you're if you're
Swede you can read Swedish then I highly
recommend not only uh the the the last
book gr skooks folk which this interview
is about but also this uh more recent
book uh which you can find basically
anywhere in a Swedish Bookshop it's
actually become really popular so check
that out and check out David's other
research and and and writings it's
really amazing
stuff for any Swedish speakers out there
I highly recommend commend David's
earlier work of course I will leave
links and all of that in the description
to to his uh research and his book so
you can check that out and again thank
you so much thank
[Music]
you